-Welcome back
to "the tonight show."
We're about to play
a brand-new game.
This is "Fake Off."
-♪ Aah, fake off ♪
♪ Fake off ♪
-I'm going to need some help
on this one,
so joining me now is the one
and only Kevin James!
Kevin, it is great to see you.
-Thank you.
-Thank you for playing this game
with me.
Here's how this works --
Kevin and I are each
going to take turns presenting
three projects
that we worked on.
The catch is that one of them
is completely fake.
We'll ask each other questions
and try to figure out
which one is made up.
And if we get it right,
we win that round.
Sound good?
-Okay.
All right. You ready?
-Yep.
-Which of these is not a real
movie I starred in, okay?
"A," "Grilled."
-Uh-huh.
"B," "The Dog House."
Or "C," "True Memoirs of
an International Assassin."
-I saw "True Memoirs,"
so that's real.
"The Dog House" feels like
that's not something you would
have done.
"Grilled," who is that in there
with you in "Grilled?"
I can't --
-It was Ray Romano.
-Oh, well I think you and Ray
know each other from standup.
And I should see "Grilled"
by the way if that --
I would say I don't believe that
you were in "The Dog House."
I think that is not a --
I believe you have been
in the dog house
in your real life.
-Right.
-But I say that is a fake movie.
-"The Dog House" is fake.
All right, you're correct.
[ Ding! ]
You're right.
It is the fake one.
I'm kind of mad. I wanted you
to jump on -- "The Dog House."
It's sad that "The Dog House"
is something that could be
considered something I did,
right?
[ Laughter ]
-No. Wait,
what would be the concept?
Do you somehow --
like your wife put --
You're in the dog house,
and so you actually start
living in the dog house?"
-Yes. With the dog.
And it becomes a buddy movie
between me and a dog.
It's got to be a buddy movie.
Right?
I do something,
the wife gets upset with me,
I'm out in the dog house,
and then we form a relationship,
and we go on the road somehow.
And he fixes me, and
I come back, and all is well.
-Okay, here we go.
Back to me now.
These questions.
-Okay.
-Which of these is not
a real album of mine?
I don't know if you knew
I had albums.
Is it "A,"
"Blow Your Pants Off."
"B," "The Bathroom Wall."
Or "C," "Greatest Hit."
-Okay.
I know "The Bathroom Wall."
So I know that one's good.
It's between "A" and "C."
I'm going to go with
"Blow Your Pants Off."
I don't think you did that.
I don't think you did
"Blow Your Pants Off."
[ Laughter ]
-You're wrong. I did do that!
-Get out of here!
When did you do --
-I won a Grammy.
-For "Blow Your Pants Off?"
-Yeah.
-And "Bathroom Wall" nothing?
-[ Laughs ]
"Bathroom wall" nothing.
"Blow Your Pants Off."
-That's -- Wait a second.
There's a bigger story here.
And it's about "Bathroom Wall"
nothing.
I'm happy for you
for "Blowing Your Pants Off,"
and good job.
This is --
It's just not fair, man.
-Thank you, finally.
We can call the Academy
and talk to somebody.
-Oh, man!
-All right, Kevin, time for the
final round.
This is for you. You ask
a question about yourself.
And if I get this right,
I'm the winner.
-All right, here we go.
Which of these is not
a real animated character
I voiced in a movie?"
"A," Old Man Meehan.
"B," Otis the Cow.
Or "C," Officer Landers.
-[ Sighs ] This is insane.
Is not a real animated character
you voice in a movie.
Old man Meehan?
Hm. Otto the Cow.
That's pretty cute.
-Otis the Cow.
-Sorry. Otis the Cow.
-Yeah.
-That was a trick question.
I just wanted to see
if you reacted. You did.
You took the bait on that one.
-Nice setup.
Nice setup.
-No problem.
So that one's real.
Officer Landers.
That seems a little fakey name,
And you just played an officer
in "Hubie Halloween."
You're not one to repeat roles.
-Right.
-I'm going to say the answer
is...
But yet, you're not old.
Why would you play
Old Man Meehan?
-Well...
-You're young.
I'm going to switch
and go flip mode.
I'm going to say
Old Man Meehan, fake.
You never did it.
-You're a son of --
You're right.
You're right, man.
[ Ding ]
I thought I had you on Landers.
-I almost got on Landers.
What was officer Landers?
-You got me -- almost got me
on Landers,
and now I want to play Meehan.
I want to play him.
-You're not old enough.
You shouldn't play
Old Man anybody.
-But you can do the
[ Old man voice ] old man voice
[ Normal voice ]
or, you know, whatever it is.
I don't know what he sounds
like, but I'd like to dig in.
-Well, apparently he sounds
like -- [ Grumbling ]
[ Both laugh ]
That gravelly...
-[ Gravelly voice ]
It's a gravelly old guy.
-[ Gravelly, old man voice ] My
old man is that type of voice.
-[ Old man voice ] Oh, yeah,
you can go that way, as well.
-Yes. Oh, yours is British.
-It -- did he -- Was he British?
-What do you mean?
Of course he was.
-Righto.
-[ Laughs ]
That was -- thank you
for playing our game.
I got to know you
a little better.
-Yeah, you did. And I know you,
and I'm still pissed off
at "Bathroom Wall."
Okay, buddy? I'm just --
This is just unacceptable.
I'm making some phone calls.